we will get started on our final session
of speakers
um
we're very lucky to have a
speaking first tao fan visiting us from
monash university in melbourne
uh
i won't do any more introduction i'll
just leave it to you to get started and
thank you very much
thank you
um hello thank you everyone my name is
tao fan i'm a research fellow at monash
university in melbourne australia i'm
part of the australian research
council's center of excellence for
automated decision making and society
and i'm also part of the emerging
technologies research lab
the paper i'm presenting today is based
on work i've published in collaboration
with my colleague scott walk who's at
the university of warwick
and together we've been thinking through
how race and racism manifests in
algorithmic culture
now there's certainly no shortage of
examples of things like racial
vilification racial discrimination other
racist actions that take place on
platforms today
and most of this is done in very
explicit ways in ways that we are able
to see
through the use of say directed racial
slurs the reward and circulation of
inflammatory racist content or the
routine delivery of demeaning results
for racialized search terms like black
girls or asian girls
these racist acts are rightly understood
as the online continuation of a
pre-existing state of affairs
the symptom of an overall racist society
the problem of bias and algorithms is
often characterized in this way
as a problem of history of repeating
itself the flaws of the past being coded
with an infrastructure which then traps
the future inside of a recursive loop
in wendy chun's words a model of
prediction that closes the world it
pretends to open
so for example a principle like garbage
in garbage out captures this really well
any model that's been trained on a
floor-to-dirty data set will reproduce
the problems inherent within that data
set
in this case it's racism in racism out
you put racist data into a model and
it'll reproduce and perpetuate that same
racism
but the provocation i'd like to make
today is that while platforms are
undeniably reproducing racism
they're also doing something which i
think is much more subtle and arguably
much more radical
they're fundamentally transforming the
category of race itself
and they're doing it in ways that has
significant consequences for how we
traditionally think identify and
confront racism racialization
so let me use an example to illustrate
between 2016 and 2020 facebook very
controversially allowed advertisers to
target users in the us using three broad
categories of what they called ethnic
affinity categories
these were african-american u.s u.s
hispanic and asian-american
and they were controversial for two main
reasons
the first was that advertisers could use
these categories to not only target but
to exclude racial groups from receiving
their advertising messages
so for example advertisers could
purchase ads targeted at facebook users
who are house hunting and then exclude
anyone
from an african-american u.s hispanic or
asian-american affinity from receiving
those ads
what as many commentators pointed out is
effectively a violation of the u.s
federal anti-discrimination laws
the second has to do with the way people
are being categorized
so facebook does not explicitly ask
users to identify themselves according
to race
instead these categories are
algorithmically determined using
behavioral data and indirect proxy
indicators like language use interests
and i p address
now there's a lot of attention being a
lot of attention analysis being placed
on that first issue of the ways in which
algorithmic techniques are being used to
continue the work of racism
in this example through racial
segregation and systematic housing
discrimination
it's an exemplary case study for what
sathya noble calls technological
redlining the use of algorithmically
driven software to reinforce oppressive
social relationships
but what receives less attention though
is that second issue which is about how
platforms and indeed algorithmic culture
more broadly is producing new forms of
racialization
new ways new modes of categorizing and
recognizing people as raced and as a
result transforming what it means to be
raced today
so my talk is roughly divided into two
parts uh in part one i'll be going into
a bit more detail about what's new in
this particular moment focusing
specifically on the post-visual or what
anna monster and adrian mckenzie have
called the in-visual aspects of
algorithmic culture
and then in part two i'll be unpacking
the specific challenge this presents for
scholars who are invested in studying
race and its effects in contemporary
culture
so over two decades ago the critical
race and cultural studies scholar paul
gilroy made the contentious proposition
that the time of race may be coming to a
close
developments in molecular biology and
digital imaging techniques like mris and
pet scans had allowed the human body to
be visualized at new previously
imperceptible scales
by rendering the body intelligible new
ways gilroy argued these
techno-scientific processes challenged
the modern representational economy
critical to the reproduction of race
if race operates operates by
differentiating and classifying bodies
based on how they look then changes in
the apparatuses that mediate how bodies
can be looked at ought to allow us to
reimagine race or indeed potentially do
away with it all together
and while there are a lot of
shortcomings with this argument what we
find compelling is the insight it offers
about the close link between
racialization and
mediation for gilroy race has to be
understood as an effect of the
techniques we use to represent it
if if racial difference is no longer
perceptible at say the genetic or the
molecular scale should it matter as a
mode of organizing bodies
in this way gilroy's post-race polemic
is attached to a post-visual discourse
like many critical race scholars gilroy
framed his argument in relation to a
conceptualization of race that is
predicated on an epistemology of
visibility
and this particular way of approaching
race has become extremely dominant
within race and critical algorithm
studies or what's sometimes called race
critical code studies
scholars like benjamin simone brown tim
nick jaboo joint bull and weenie for
instance have given us really vital and
incisive critiques based on how new
technologies perceive or don't perceive
racialized traits like blackness
for benjamin and brown in particular
whose work explicitly builds on the
approach of scholars like fenon
visualization is a central aspect for
processes like digital epidermalization
that is explicit acts of looking and
interpolation
so how then
do we account of the example i
introduced earlier
on facebook
of modes of racialization that
explicitly cannot be seen
either because it's a constitution
occurs beyond human scrutiny at scales
imperceptible to the human or because
it's deliberately obscured and opaque
because they operate for example through
say proprietary processes
take another example
in 2013 in the 2013 snowden leaks
it was revealed that the u.s national
security agency used a procedural
algorithmic tool to determine whether an
individual could be classified as
foreign for the purposes of state
surveillance
under u.s law u.s citizens are afforded
privacy protections under their
constitution's fourth amendment to
bypass this law and to justify their
collect their expansive collected or
surveillance program the us government
created a method of determining
citizenship by measuring foreignness as
a likelihood percentage
media scholar john chaney lippel puts it
this way
if an individual's foreigners is found
to be at or above 51 confidence then
that individual legally becomes a
foreigner and thus loses the right to
privacy
the data points used to determine
foreign
yet operate in ways that reproduce and
reconstruct ethnic racial and cultural
ideas of national identity
it's this
post-visual logic we argue that disrupts
how race is being conceptualized and
acted upon today
the challenge that we have now then is
to try and find a conceptual language
and methodological approach that can be
used to think identify and confront
racialization in this post-visual regime
so this is easier said than done
precisely because the novel techniques
of racialization associated with this
regime are particularly good at
obfuscating themselves and the way that
they produce racialized difference
typically
studies of media and digital culture
have conceptualized race as a visual
process and studied racialization using
visual methods
dominant discussions of race and
algorithms have primarily focused on
visual applications such as facial
recognition
or the disproportionate impacts of
systems on communities that are
racialized
visually again the work of scholars like
simone brown or sophia noble who focus
on the effects of the technologization
of anti-blackness on black subjects and
black communities
in much of this work the effect of
algorithmic systems on race has been
primarily read through the principle of
garbage in garbage out that is scholars
tend to identify racist outputs produced
by algorithmic systems as products of
racist inputs
these inputs are typically understood in
a few key ways
in the form of data that is biased
because it inadequately represents
racialized communities or because it
reflects historical injustice to
prejudice
and what we want to stress is that the
concepts of race entered into such
systems are not necessarily the same
ones that come out
the model of garbage in garbage out
misses what happens in the middle when
data is subject to algorithmic
techniques of sorting classifying and
categorizing
what the existing discussion of race and
digital technology has overlooked we
think is how these algorithmic
techniques transform the inputs they
work on
a category like ethnic affinities is
generated using inductive and
correlative machine learning
processes
there is not necessarily a direct causal
relation between the data that the
system has on you and the inferences it
makes about you
these inferences might emerge from
correlations between behavioral data
points held on millions of users or
through proxies that acts that act as
stand-ins at several removes for
explicitly racial categories
moreover these categories are striking
because they reorder the relationship
between racialized categorization and
visibility
as louisa moore notes critical accounts
of the rise of algorithms have placed
great emphasis on the power of
algorithms to visualize to reprogram
vision or indeed to see which is not
otherwise available to human regimes
visuality
yet algorithms cause great anxiety
because they operate on a plane in
excess of human visibility and at scales
that are inscrutable to the human
what we're referring to here as as post
as a post-visual regime now encapsulates
large-scale data collection and
processing which occurs at scales and
through processes that are not only not
visible to us beyond our perception
but which also produce effects in
registers that are also not at all
seeable
adam monster and adrian mckenzie refer
to these these forms of platform seeing
as as in visual perception arguing that
despite visual techniques and practices
continuing to proliferate from data
visual visualization through to lidar
technologies for capturing non-optical
images the visual itself as a paradigm
for how to see and observe is being
evacuated
and that space is now occupied by a
different kind of perception
for them this new kind of perception is
tied to ensembles of software hardware
and platforms that understand images in
non-representational terms
similar we're arguing that large-scale
data processing generates novel racial
formations recapitulating them as what
we call data formations
here racialized bodies are figured not a
single coherent subjects but is shifting
clusters of data or as lee put it on
wednesday as fragmentary correlational
probabilistic
these data formations conceive us in new
ways and we are in ways that we
ourselves aren't able to see
new media scholar bernard reiner has
recently described these kinds of
computational systems as engines of
order
that is systems that use classification
techniques to make order out of a
surfeit of data
but engines of order are also engines of
difference
in his words they not only imply forms
of standardization homogenization and
commensuration but also produce their
own vectors of differentiation
the differences they propagate take real
people as their objects but do so in
ways that are extremely difficult to
reverse engineer and consequently to
resist
because these techniques are inductive
the categories they produce depend on
the data they're trained on in the
absence of a category explicitly
labelled race these technologies produce
racializations indirectly inferring them
from correlations between other
categories or through the use of proxies
with enough data the invisible
correlates of race like postcode
language group degrees of contact with
institutions like the criminal justice
system render race actionable once again
and these techniques change race's
epistemological basis
establishing a novel non-visual ground
for a novel racializing logic
we want to identify a break a disruption
instituted by technology that employs
these inductive logics
some forms of data processing are racist
because they incorporate data that bears
the trace of a race to society garbage
in garbage out
but large-scale inductive data
processing also institutes another more
pernicious kind of racism
this racism emerges in and through
correlative models and is endogenous to
those models
behind the ideological smoke screen that
such technologies are post-racial the
power to classify to differentiate and
crucially determine context produces a
wholly novel and new capacity to
racialize
the infrastructure of racialization
instituted by such technologies might
ultimately reproduce existing forms of
racialized inequality but the capacity
to produce race by other means turns
racial categories into something else
entirely
emergent epi phenomena of large-scale
automated data processing
in short racial formations as data
formations i'm just concluding now
so i'm just going to conclude with a few
speculative reflections on the
methodological problem posed by
algorithmic racialization
this post-visual regime i've begun to
sketch raises methodological and
political challenges for scholars of
race and technology
while it's important to note that the
argument that algorithmic systems can
recapitulate or perpetuate already
existing regimes of inequality like
racism our argument is that they carry
out a more fundamental operation
that they've begun to transform the
category of race itself
correlated inferred and acted on via
proxies racial formations as data
formations not only transforms the
category of race they also locate the
sites of racialization
uh elsewhere
behind places that can they can
typically be identified and contested
out of sight and out of easy reach
to study the novel racial formations
that are produced by such systems we
need to go beyond races and coding into
data
we also need to go beyond how such modes
of racialization are felt
most critically we also need to go
beyond critical accounts of mediated
racialization that operate in visual
registers
we've started to do this work in
analyzing examples like facebook's
ethnic affinities
and all this is uh these are
particularly significant points for
scholars invested in questions of race
and culture because it confronts us with
some important questions
how can we advocate against a process
that operates beyond our perception
how can we keep up with the dynamic pace
of classification classifications that
are being assessed and reassessed with
every new piece of behavioral data
and how do these issues make redundant
the traditional tools of resistance
things like advocating for inclusion or
representation make no sense within a
post-visual regime
how can we resist a category we don't
even know we've been placed within
and how do we form communities of
solidarity under those conditions
thank you very much
thanks tao um
and now we have fabian offered